I do miss dancing I'd miss my family
there'd be my family for the last decade
Cheryl Burke may not be competing on
Season 22 of dancing with the stars but
that doesn't mean that she won't be
watching I'm the number one fan like I'm
still gonna tune in Monday night the
dancing pro made some predictions about
the new season with ET at the hrc gala
over the weekend i would say i think
mark and Paige they're gonna be great
and i would say wanye and Lindsey those
are my two winners I don't know they're
definitely gonna be in the final Jody i
hear is great too I think it's gonna be
there's a lot of great dancers I here at
this season so everyone better chacha it
out I still get like the juicy gossip
cuz you know I'm still feel great friend
Mark Ballas is a great friend of mine
Tony Dovolani obviously more like the
og's we started like back in season two
so you know I just saw him the other
night I helped him with his Argentine
tango with Marla so it's like you know
we're still going to always be a family
um I do miss it I just you know maybe
one day they'll ask me to be like a
guest judge or like no you know I would
love to be a part of in some capacity to
the future